hi there this is Steve Kaufman now I'm
gonna talk a little bit about the
exchange that I've had with some
language and literacy teachers and I
posted on my blog the linguist on
language some of the comments that these
English teachers have made this is honor
on a listserv which is a community of
people who exchange opinions via email
and the subject here was literacy and
social change and the gist of of the
comments from just about I would say you
know 8 out of 10 of the commenters was
that that in teaching literacy they also
have to teach social change and social
change will sound like somehow bound up
in this idea that our society is very
bad capitalism consumerism power
relationships you know women's rights
etc and if people just learn to read and
if they aren't aware of how what they
are reading is carrying all these bad
messages then they won't really have
benefited from from literacy I'm not
exaggerating you know I'm just looking
at some of the things that were that I
posted you can see them on my blog but
here's one for example this is a person
who teaches English
I guess you left out the real big part
of learning to read the skill is not
complete without understanding what you
have read
and internalize in the text I don't
quite know how you read without
understanding at some level what you
have read you may not have the same
understanding as someone else but you
understood you understood something
otherwise you didn't read it
it would seem to me anyway she goes on
here is where critical thinking comes on
to the stage and of course to these
language teachers and literacy teachers
just teaching the language or teaching
people how to read is not enough of a
challenge has that gone to this teaching
Teachers College they've learned all
kinds of theories about power
relationships and stuff from they want
to lead their charges to this greater
emancipation or whatever and so she says
as beginners I guess surface meaning of
text can only open at a very limited
level and what happens the deeper
meanings where it lies the Epiphany the
Assumption here again is that only the
teacher can understand the text and only
the teachers understanding of that text
is correct that the learners
understanding of that text is is not
valid well I will understand the text
differently for someone else and I think
I have the right to have my own
understanding even my own
misunderstanding of whatever remedy
anyway she was on the issue of social
change and it's definition is because we
now use it in this shorter form this is
an English teacher who wrote these words
I repeat the issue of social change and
it's definition is because we now use it
in its shorter form socialized change
carries the weight of the intended
she writes change that is collectively
agreed and executed by a majority of
those in any community is what I think
most of us have in mind blah blah blah
she goes on I mean there's only one
example I mean aside from the fact that
that she doesn't use English very well I
mean I read a number of these posts I
have a sense of what she's trying to say
and that is that we have to change we
have to bring about she says through our
literacy efforts bring about social
change
well societies change and if you want to
I mean I feel if a person wants to
affect change in society in one
direction or another that's a very valid
thing to do we've had you know religious
missionaries we've had you know
socialist fascist you name it
some people are pro-abortion against
abortion in favor of I don't know
whatever go ahead
but why mask that as literacy teaching
you know teaching literacy is teaching
people what how to read so it seems to
me it's like what do you want to read
about what do you like you like the
sports baseball let's read the sports
page here's another one I believe that
social change will continue to be
hindered until society as a whole
begins to recognize value and celebrate
marginalized literacies and practices I
see part of my job as an instructor to
make cracks in that which we in
quotation know to be importation
literacy to keep an open mind to
encourage you to see the significance of
their primary discourses I just don't
understand
no she goes on any notion of capital L
literacy is a social construct literacy
is a social construct it's not just a
matter whether you can read or not it's
a social construct which he says
invariably tied to structures of power
and inherently political I choose to
believe she says there are many
literacies tied to social cultural
transactional practices lots of jargon
right yet only certain ones are being
valuable enough to be taught reproduced
in formal education blah blah blah
I'm suggesting that social change might
be realized when we allow traditional
notions of literacy to be Rican seen on
the terms of those who are sometimes
mistakenly deemed to be without it I
mean all right enough quoting in all
this stuff full of jargon full of what
different University to me it's simple
either can read or you can't be if you
can't read you are at a disadvantage it
doesn't make you a bad person it just
means that you're missing out on
opportunities opportunities to learn
many things there are many jobs that you
cannot get if you can't read and
therefore most people want to read and
most people particularly want their
children to be know the issue of
critical thinking he's very important
well first of all let's go back to
social change we've had a lot of social
change some is better for the better
good some is not today for example 30 40
years ago homosexuality was a terrible
crime today a majority of people support
gay marriage
I sort of like gay marriage let us say
that gays can do what they want I don't
believe in forcing religions to
celebrate gay marriage if the religions
don't believe in that now the resonation
have the freedom to have their own
beliefs but it's early doesn't bother me
that a gay couple want live together
celebrate their union and however
whatever formerly one not a problem and
so these are societal changes that have
occurred attitudinal changes but by the
same token we have more divorce today we
have more drug addiction today we have a
number of societal problems that are
worse today than they were 30 40 years
the family structure has broken down and
in particular in certain communities and
this has led to more crime and and more
unhappiness so changing society doesn't
mean making it better but I do recognize
that a lot of people are out there
trying to change society in ways that
they think will make it better and I
have no trouble with that just don't
confuse that with literacy training
literacy training is about trying to
somehow help people who can't read very
well to read better and period critical
thinking now all of these literacy
instructors they're always on about the
critical thinking are gonna teach
critical thinking they don't think
critically every one of them turns out
this jargon filled gibberish that I've
been quoting here and they don't
challenge they quote someone
Freyr said this they don't even
challenge prayer they don't question
anything of what he had to say is it
alright some of it right but do I agree
with what don't I agree no frere said
this therefore that's true and and of
course in my arguments they come back
music now that we have refuted your
argument we all know you have a refuted
anything all you did was disagree with
me I didn't refute you I just disagreed
with you you disagree with me now but
they don't apply for legal thinking and
that is why at our universities there's
like 90% of the faculty of American
Universities support the democratic
now does that suggest that there's real
critical thinking happening there I
don't think so
one thing that I'm interested in is this
whole issue of multiculturalism I'm
against multi I in North America I think
people who come to Canada should become
Canadian and fit into the mainstream of
the established cultures English
speaking French speaking or native if
that works and there was a lady at the
University of McMaster who wrote an
interesting paper on English Canadian as
a national identity and that is a
reality there's many people with Italian
polish Chinese Japanese you name it
Ukrainian names that feel themselves
that identify as English Canadian not
like from England but english-speaking
Canadians it's a national identity
she wrote a paper on it I phoned her to
follow up because I was interested in a
subject she said she was not allowed to
continue doing that work because she
received so much criticized criticism
from her peers in the critical thinking
infused academic field so I'm running
out of time but I'll continue